[Music]
welcome to Frontier Feud so I'm your
host uh bar yourone I'm a partner at
amplify we the First Investors in
technical Founders and I invest in data
and AI companies I'm very excited to be
here Frontier feuding in my favorite
City New York City and today on stage we
have some amazing folks competing for
prizes and eternal glory and all that
good stuff so we're going to introduce
our teams uh do not let these smiling
faces deceive you we are here to compete
uh before we do intros for the teams
just an audience feeler who here in the
audience including those on stage have
watched Family Feud before quick show of
hands
most people for those of you uh who
haven't the premise is pretty simple the
nuances you'll learn with the game so we
surveyed 100 AI Engineers on a series of
questions folks on stage are going to
guess the answers to those questions and
the most popular answers from the survey
are going to get the most points so feel
free to follow along and guess yourself
in the audience as we go along uh if you
don't like the answers you can look to
your left and look to your right and
blame your neighbors no I'm just kidding
in all seriousness thank you so much to
everyone who filled out that survey
before and so we're going to do some
quick intros um we have on my left M you
can kick it off tell us who you are what
you do and your Tech hot take we're
going to do quick
intros cool hey everyone my name is m
here uh I work at anthropic um my tech
hot take is I think uh let's say have
the fiveish people training big models
today at least one of them will no
longer be training AI models by the end
of the
year mic drop but really mic pass so
John hi guys I'm John I work at
anthropic and my tech hot take is I
think AIS make really good
therapists hi I'm Tina um I work at
reflection AI it's a startup building
coding agents and my tech hot take is
that everybody working in our industry
should spend like 20 minutes a day with
just a pie pce of paper and a pencil um
and think like non AI interrupted
thoughts thank
you hi I'm sha I'm the product lead for
the Gemini developer apis working with
paig uh I have two my first tech hard
take is a followup from Tina's I think
it'll be important for people to do what
Tina said because eventually when you
have ai models representing you they'll
need some good content to be trained on
I think I'll save my next one for later
I love it excellent Paige you want to
start your side heck yeah greetings
everyone we on the stage did not get to
vote in the survey so just be aware that
uh we did not pregame it no fraud no
fraud um uh my name is Paige I work at
Google deep mine leading uh engineering
for AI deell team um uh and I guess my
tech hot take is is that uh speed
forward ahead a year and a half I think
that the majority of deployed models
will be on device um and we'll be seeing
a trend more towards smaller models um
that are uh kind of orchestrated
together maybe uh hypers specialized for
a specific task um as opposed to relying
just on larger models um and sending
data elsewhere to do interesting
things uh my name's Colin uh you might
remember me from my talk earlier today
I'm a researcher at augment code
building AI coding tools before that I
was at Fair Facebook AI research here in
New York on working on AI for board
games I I just had to get out both hot
takes since I had two two ones so one is
that in the future dating apps will be
our AI dating each other um two is I
don't think Transformers are the final
architecture because eventually we'll
build these models using biological
materials oh
snap hi my name is Petra
I'm the product manager of factuality
for the AI answer at the top of the
Google search page my hot take is that
um chatting with uh one bot oneon-one is
boring and in the future most
conversations will have at least two
other bots in the in the room with you I
love it hello uh I'm Stephen uh I'm
joining thinking machines soon um and my
hot take is that if you think we're
hitting a token wall that sounds like a
skill issue to
me I love it amazing so with that let's
get started I'm gonna have Paige and
Mahir join me not that you're so far
from me excellent great so the objective
is like hit this as fast as possible
right yes okay so so um so whoever
buzzes first has the first chance to
answer this question so I'm going to ask
a question and we'll take it from here
so we asked 100 AI engineers name the
most influential AI researcher God dang
it I looked at the screen okay what's
your what's your guess uh Ilia
satar okay we have Ilia Nom shazir Noom
shazir very influential but not on the
board not in our not in our top eight
answers so your team decides if to play
or
pass all right we're GNA play You're
Gonna Play You're Gonna Play okay
awesome so John it's it's your turn to
guess someone okay get another person
but you can stay
there we're working at The Kinks
influencer cheating
frud
Andre answer good
answer all right Tina how about you Jeff
Hinton oh an excellent one but
H oh sorry did you say Jeff Hinton yeah
oh that's on
me um I thought you said something else
great I the the the lead author on the
Transformer paper the attention all you
need paper we need we need a specific
name
sorry um
sorry I'm having a literal like I know
the name but I uh I'm having a literal
like uh we're gonna
have yeah I think but we we you already
had a strike that doesn't count so we're
gonna we keep it we're netting at one go
[Music]
here I'm gonna say yan laon yan laon we
do have Yan
laon okay why do we keep going we just
keep going because you're winning oh
until we lose yeah until you lose oh I
didn't
I uh wait if you want to lose here's
your OPP
bani uh no so not on the board
okay um what was the question
again good question so name the most
influential AI researcher um I'm going
to say sam Alman Sam Alman it's a good
one it's not on the board oh that ironic
and so s we are on three strike so your
team needs to
deliberate and if you pick an answer you
actually steal the
points we have four options on the
board and for those who are joining the
question is we asked 100 AI Engineers
name the most influential AI research
all right I'm giving you a five
four you're good all
right um I'll do Jeff
Dean um Jeff Dean is not on the board
which
is what I had registered earlier um okay
so that goes to uh Roo's basilisk
and we're GNA go what were the rest yeah
I'll show you yeah I'll show you the
rest of
them so these were the ones that were
guest we also have Andrew in we
have we have f f Lee and we have yosua
Benjo there is a longtail very
influential researchers too but they
they're only eight spots so all great
guesses okay next
all right uh I think John and Colin what
is yeah you want to know the question
yeah patience so name the top
considerations when choosing a
model oh I think your's is
broken I think he
first more
[Laughter]
[Music]
passion uh come aggressively this team
well yes name the top considerations
when choosing a
model
intelligence I'm going to be very
literal very smart answer very smart
answer
MH you have an opportunity to to guess
uh safety
safety uh is actually not on
here and so why don't we get uh Tina and
Petra to
guess am I next yeah oh um
price so cost is the number one answer
which actually surprised me I don't know
if like maybe raise of hands if you
would have guessed price now you know so
hindsight's 2020 that wouldn't have been
obvious to me but means that you guys
will continue with this answer and we'll
we'll we'll continue from
there latency
latency uh
yes uh eval benchmark
scores I some of these things are
ambiguous but I'm going to put it under
don't don't kill me accuracy performance
[Music]
okay that's like
everything okay um uh the CEO the
CEO good answer good answer good answer
good moving on Oh I thought because we
Miss oh no we your te got it um like
where the the model is being served like
if it's on Prem or you know uh no we're
not going to count that one but it's a
good answer okay this team has an
opportunity to steal these
points I hear some folks in the audience
think they're ready to steal
so I love that about you I love the
confidence oh my God
we can make a guess that was no it
wasn't uh open source versus closed
Source okay so with that you guys get 63
points cuz you stole the stole the
points by
getting so it's a pretty close game
going into the third and final
question yeah EXC all
right
sorry I know everyone everyone wants the
an who has like very strong upper body
strength so so here here are the
answers oh capabilities yeah these are
the
answers great thanks for keeping me
honest everyone in the audience and
everyone here so all right next so who
do we have coming up Petra and Tina
incredible you can do it so both in the
front Okay this requires uh Power is
what we've learned so um are you ready
ready yeah okay we asked 100 AI
Engineers name a buzzword
sorry it's okay I'm not offended but
name a buzz word everyone in AI is tired
of
hearing agents agents
what do you all think
yes okay but you still have an
opportunity to guess because you could
get the number one answer oh okay
um but you have to guess
now I'm giving you three two one sorry
um
okay so it's going to go to this
team and um uh sha it goes to you we
asked 100 AI Engineers name a buzz word
everyone in AI is tired of
hearing I'm going to start my five four
multimodality multimodality
uh we do not have
multimodality but I don't know where
this strike came from so first
strike uh I'm GNA go with
co-pilots co-pilots gu what do we think
he asked or no to co-pilots that's a
very good
guess I think it's a good okay good
answer good answer uh but
no AGI
AGI okay what what does the audience
think
AGI all right it seems like we think
it's a good answer and no just kidding
yes the number one answer
hii all right
Tina oh
um deep
[Laughter]
seek no no deep seek so this team has an
opportunity to steal
but you're right maybe maybe for like
the
week yeah you're back you're so
back safety
safety so unfortunately safety is not
one of the
answers so the these were the additional
answers people here are sick of rag and
prompt
engineering um but what this means is is
that we have a winner which is Roo's
basilis but amazing amazing work by paig
attention and the mixture of experts and
so we're going to move to the fast money
round do you guys have two
Representatives all right you two are
going and that means John leave the
stage I'll call you when you're
ready all right we're moving into fast
money and uh so some of you have seen
Family Feud but we're playing fast money
the goal is for the two of them together
to get to 200 points uh you have Mah
here 20 seconds to answer five questions
uh if you can't think of anything just
say pass and we can come back to it at
the end or never um and if you hear a
buzzer sound let me check that it
works beautiful your answer wasn't one
of the surveyed questions so you can
keep asking or or move on all right are
you ready y okay
uh name an AI tool that Engineers love
cursor uh name the sorry I didn't start
the
clock name the job most at risk of AI
disruption software Engineers name the
most influential AI paper in history
attention is all you
need name the biggest nightmare for AI
engineer at 2
a.m. uh Hardware failure
okay so we got through four but they
were good ones so name an AI tool that
Engineers love you said cursor cursor is
the number one answer
EXC we asked name the job most at risk
of AI
disruption you said software
engineering that is the number three
answer we asked name the most
influential AI paper in
history what do you think demolished
attention is all is by far the number
one answer uh name the biggest nightmare
for AI at 2
am. failure Hardware
failure you know what we'll give it
we'll give it as info problem okay okay
yeah um and so you're going into the
round 140 points you want to tap tap
John in
John ran away he got scared no there we
go
amazing incredible so John big things
you have 25 seconds and you got to stand
back there you have 25 seconds to answer
five questions um and if you can't think
of anything just say pass and we'll come
back to it if we have time at the end uh
if you hear a buzzer sound it means that
either your answer wasn't isn't on the
board or M's already answered it you
ready yep um okay and I'm going to start
your
timer name an AI tool Engineers
[Music]
love oh um
CT um name the job most at risk of
disruption um
artists
uh name the most influential AI paper in
history uh Transformers is all attention
is all you
need okay so we have model apis which
is uh the third answer on the board we
have name the job mode you said you said
artist so I'm going to give you content
creationwriting it's a little
ambiguous and attention is all you need
was already uh selected by Mahir but
well I'll let you pick the next question
which is name the biggest nightmare for
AI engineer at 2 a.m. someone wrote In
Cold email from a VC so I will talk to
after uh uh Cuda SS Cuda SS okay well
you know what your teammates because you
think alike and you think you you think
of great answers so let me just show you
the number one answers here which are a
cursor data entry for the job most at
risk of AI disruption attention is all
you need the the top paper so that was a
good one just already taken the biggest
nightmare an outage of the model or
otherwise and an industry that would
benefit the most from a My
Healthcare uh so with that we have well
you lost the 200
points but I think that you're still
winners and you're all winners and we
have a few prizes outside that I think
someone is
bringing
so we have a massive llama for this team
we have rainbow lamba beanie babies for
everyone we have ai engineering books
and gift cards to your favorite
restaurants in New York yor and maybe we
can bring them out and leave uh thank
you so much for joining us for Frontier
Feud and we're going to see you next
year we're running a massive
survey on the state of AI engineering
going to be presenting it at the June AI
engineer World Fair so if you liked some
of the teaser questions this will get
much more in depth into the tools folks
are using uh the workflows that AI
Engineers have and it's a way for the
industry to be more transparent uh so
thank you uh you can find the QR code or
the link here if you want to participate
in that survey on the state of AI
engineering amazing
[Applause]
[Music]